It's not hard to imagine why people flock to Holland on foot, by bike,...
...and well, on pretty much anything with wheels...
...when winter is finally over and the country springs to life.
This legendary land of water and windmills is after all the tulip capital of the world.
And nowhere are they more brilliant and beautiful...
...than along the 40-kilometer route of Holland's flower parade, the Bloemencorso,...
...or at the famed Keukenhof Gardens.
Each year at the end of April, more than a million people, many of them tourists,...
...line the roads of the Dutch countryside south of Amsterdam.
They're here to welcome what's known as the "Face of Spring."
It's a phenomenal show of flower power:...
...from fire-breathing dragons to flights of fancy.
Its massive floats and marching bands take all day to wend their way...
...through well over a dozen Dutch villages,...
...sometimes to a distinctly tropical beat.
But where green thumbs really go big each spring is at the Keukenhof...
...where some 7 million bulbs are hand planted each fall...
...and erupt into elaborate shows of color come spring.